- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome back
to "The Super Slow Show."
Dan, I feel like
we've become well known
for our usage
of giant balloons.
Ow! Ow!
It's true.
Love a giant balloon.
Now we're on the spin rig
with a giant balloon.
Yeah, this time we filled it
with hydrogen air.
We're gonna blow it up,
hopefully get a huge
fireball going on
while we're
spinning round it.
Camera's gonna be
whipping round
a thousand frames a second.
We've also got a camera
up in the sky
pointing down
a thousand frames
so the plume goes towards it
and should look
gnarly and weird.
Nice and juicy.
Let's go.
Let's go hide.
( theme music playing )
Three, two, one, blow.
- Oh.
- Ah.
There was a bit
of a delay on that one.
Yeah, I was like, "Why isn't
the balloon popping there?"
I would say
it was a deep wumpf.
It was. It was,
like almost closing, like,
an expensive car door.
Dan: Ooh,
what's going on in there?
Gav: Feels like there's,
like, a China ball.
I feel like I don't wanna see
through the fire.
- I want it to be--
- I want it to be thick.
Like if you threw a steak
through I, it would come out--
- Medium rare.
- Exactly.
We just need
some darker flame, don't we?
Yeah, I think so.
You know what?
I think we should just--
sod the balloons.
Get rid of those.
This video
is about balloons.
- Get rid of them.
- No, no-no.
Let's just have
some gratuitous fireballs.
- Let's get a bucket of,
like, dirty--
- Yeah.
We know what we're after.
They know what we're after.
- We want a big, fat fireball.
- Yeah.
- And a camera spinning
around it.
- Yeah.
Hydrogen just don't cut it.
- No, no.
- Get that H out of here.
Supposedly,
in that small black box,
is a fireball
just waiting to be released.
How'd they pack it in there?
Luckily, I've got a trigger,
so whenever we're ready...
Three, two, one...
Oh!
That was loud.
Now, that's what we're after.
- See that smoke ring.
- Look at that smoke ring.
Smoke doing up there.
( laughing )
Imagine doing that and just,
like, ( inhales )...
Yeah, like some cool guy
in a bar who's like...
Yeah.
( laughs )
That's what happened.
And it's slightly
on fire still.
Ooh.
( giggles )
Well, I think I got
my fireball kicks there.
Happy with that.
That should look class.
Gav:
Look at those lovely clouds
on a serene morning.
Dan: Nice day, for sure.
Let's disrupt it a little bit.
( together )
Whoa.
Dan: Oh, wow.
Gav: That's cool.
Look at all
the tiny, fine details.
Just spinning around.
- Hefty.
- Cool.
Dan:
So that's the fuel coming out.
Gav: And ignition.
Dan: Oh.
So I love how this video
started off
as a video about balloons,
and it just ended
with a huge fireball.
- Yeah.
- Uh...
I mean, at its core,
it was about a fireball.
So we didn't stray too far
from the subject.
Yeah, okay, that's fair.
I feel slightly nervous
looking down
the barrel of that
even though it's all gone.
Do you think you'd get
a singed eyebrows,
your eyebrows would go
in this position or just...
- Yeah, pains to think about.
- Yeah, I think so.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that lovely 360-degree view
of a fireball.
Thanks for watching,
and we'll see you
in the next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
Isn't that right, Dan?
Absolutely.
Have you got any more
of those fireballs?
Can we do some more?
Just for fun, yeah?
Don't try this at home.
Good luck trying it at home.
- Okay, you ready?
- Yeah.
All right.
Three, two, one...
( classical music playing )
Hi, guys, we can't wait
to show you more episodes
from this show.
Loads of other videos
for you to check out.
If you haven't already,
be sure to subscribe now
for the latest updates,
special guests
and big explosions.
So click here
if you love explosions.
Everyone
loves explosions.
That's true.
( mutters )
I mean, you have
to click there?
I think so, yeah.
I've already
clicked in it
Click.